[Musique]
le caire ne semble pas avoir beaucoup
changé depuis dix ans en apparence les
minarets domine toujours le paysage et
la ville égyptienne
les rues sont encore bons gestionnaires
les trottoirs bondés thé chez les à
thala ont certes toujours le jus fait
avec les membres et les oranges du
jardin quand nous avions rencontré la
famille à thala en 2010 c'est la maman
qui est réservé les jours où l'on était
une des toutes premières femmes en
égypte arbitrer des matchs de soccer
à l'époque elle prenait des cours
d'anglais dans l'espoir d' arbitrer dans
des tournois internationaux depuis son
rêve s'est réalisé quand même si charles
koffi votre rigueur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
révolte de 2011 mona doit aussi faire l'
arbitre entre son jeune frère qui
manifestent et ses parents qui craignent
pour sa sécurité son père approuvent le
retour de l'armée au pouvoir depuis 2000
13 bat l'italienne michoko ce guide d'un
guide a réussi six en moto
mais l'état policier est de retour en
force avec d'importantes restrictions à
la liberté d'expression et à celle de
manifester
la place tahrir est désormais occupé par
des forces de l'ordre en civil
le régime du président abdel fattah
al-sisi tolèrent mal les critiques sans
crainte dans heroes sont candidats au
freedom of expression jeune andrew barr
forces au dax
nobody knows
personne ne sait quand les arrestations
et les emprisonnements ne sont pas
logiques officiellement la police arrête
des gens qui seraient une menace à la
sécurité de l'état
mais il est impossible de comprendre
pourquoi un militant se fait arrêter et
pas l'autre
là ils sont hors ce match à mieux les
deux claques cooking with the wild west
indian harbour and docks security chose
là bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à présent la prison on connaît bien chez
les nakache militants de mère en fils
fahrid a été emprisonné dans les années
1970 parce qu'elle était membre du parti
communiste il légal à l'époque son fils
est un des nombreux militants des droits
de la personne incarcérée l'automne
dernier sans accusation anto deuil est
très belle
because my mind la militante n'hésite
pas à dénoncer ces conditions même si
elle a récemment été nommée sénatrice
par le président elle souhaite faire
changer le code familial
toujours basé sur la charia because fois
moindre il y est
[Applaudissements]
madame nakache était aussi à la place
tahrir comme des millions d'égyptiens
elle a rêvé de grands changements qui
tarde à venir
mais elle ne se décourage pas
verismic trésor au pire pour le cndp est
en partie une stricte des loges
very very small victorieuse l'une de ses
victoires
c'est l'adoption de quotas pour
augmenter le nombre de femmes élues au
parlement égyptien il est passé en dix
ans de 5 à 25% et le conseil des
ministres compte maintenant huit femmes
un sommet historique absolu à bloc
you're bringing mois et aux gender
l'état des choses jen responsable
adjoint des responsables allaient tomber
les cris de joie de la place tahrir nous
pas fait taire ceux des nombreuses
femmes agressées durant la révolution
avant 2011
les violences contre les femmes étaient
un sujet tabou en egypte les viols de la
place tahrir ont déposé une prise de
conscience collective
mais oui oui mais comment tous pic à 1
une claudine gagnerait on vous le disait
mais progresse
c'est une autre victoire des égyptiennes
depuis 10 ans leur prise de parole a
forcé les autorités à combattre les
violences faites aux femmes
les agressions et les excisions demeure
un fléau mais elles sont en baisse
highco davout steyn pro road to be proud
windows 12 des voix les égyptiens ont
aussi gagné des points sur le terrain de
soccer faïza haidar est devenue en
octobre dernier la première femme à
entraîner une équipe masculine
professionnels faiza et mona ne peuvent
pas descendre dans la rue pour
manifester
c'est avec un ballon qu'elle combat que
proie des moeurs qui touche encore
beaucoup d'égyptiens
faïza d'y venir d'une région où les
femmes ne sortent de la maison que pour
être mariée puis enterré la voir gagner
des championnats bousculer les
mentalités à venir à 3,1 en 2011
les égyptiens ont découvert la puissance
de leurs voix collective
ils ont fait tomber deux dictateurs en
moins de deux ans le régime militaire a
tiré des leçons est ressorti
l'artillerie lourde pour étouffer cette
liberté d'expression
nos comptes pro maiwenn is right mais
ces femmes militantes politicienne et
athlètes continuent d'avancer et de
changer leur monde
un pas à la fois
[Musique]